sea de x igual a la raíz cúbica de x
cúbica más 1 cuál de las siguientes es
equivalente a ye de 7 x muy bien esto va
a ser divertido sabemos que de x es
igual a la raíz cúbica de x cúbica más 1
cuál de las siguientes funciones es
equivalente a 7 x bueno vamos a evaluar
a james de x cada vez que veas una x en
7x las vamos a reemplazar porque de x
parece un poco confuso o tal vez un poco
desalentador porque nos referimos a
componer una función con sí misma pero
al final todo tendrá sentido tenemos la
raíz cúbica de algo elevado a la tercera
potencia más 1 y en este caso ese algo
es pie de x pero a que es igual de equis
bueno es igual a todo esto por lo tanto
esto será igual a la raíz cúbica de 7x
que es la raíz cúbica de x cúbica más 1
y ahora hay que llevar esto a la tercera
potencia y sumar 1
sólo necesitamos evaluar esto a que se
da igual
bueno será igual a la raíz cúbica de y
si tengo la raíz cúbica de algo y lo
elevó al cubo es lo mismo que tener algo
elevado a la un tercio y después
elevarlo a la tercera potencia así que
todo esto se evalúa en x cúbica + 1
una vez más si tienes la raíz cúbica de
algo y todo esto está elevado al cubo
obtienes de resultado el algo original
tal vez entiende mejor así si tengo la
raíz cúbica de a y esto lo elevó al cubo
obtengo simplemente a y es exactamente
lo que hice
la raíz cúbica de x cúbica más 1 esto
elevado al cubo es simple y
sencillamente x cúbica más 1 ya esto
tenemos que sumarle 1 así que todo esto
será igual a la raíz cúbica de x pública
más 2 es decir esta es la opción
correcta